what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and I know that ever
since San Diego Comic-Con this year and
Disney's d23 Expo fans have been
wondering when exactly are we going to
be getting the final trailer for Black
Panther wakanda forever and also the
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania they showed both trailers at sdcc
and then again at d23 this was exclusive
footage that was shown obviously nobody
outside of the convention saw the
footage that was released because it was
not released to the public which of
course made some fans upset who couldn't
attend and that of course sparked the
question when are they going to release
that footage those two trailers to the
public and while d23 did show us more
than just black panther wakanda forever
and Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
showing us Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
Echo and the Marvel's we can't account
for when we're going to see all of the
trailers but we can talk about when to
expect the Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania trailer and the Black
Panther 2 final trailer and these
updates are actually both coming from
Marvel Studios let's start with black
panther 2 because that is the next movie
that is about to come out in November we
have a little over a month now until
black panther wakanda forever hits
theaters and it looks like we have found
out when the tickets for the movie are
going to be going on sale according to
the Reddit user bjk man who posted
accurate release dates for tickets for
both doctor strange and the Multiverse
of Madness and Thor love and thunder so
they have a good track record according
to that Reddit user tickets for black
panther wakanda forever are ready to go
on sale Monday October 3rd and according
to this Reddit user he or she works at a
movie theater which is how they know so
be prepared to get your tickets this
Monday but also be prepared for either
another trailer or a special look this
is what Marvel Studios does when tickets
go on sale they accompany those ticket
sales those announcements with new
footage and or a new trailer and
considering the fact that we've only
gotten a teaser trailer for Black
Panther wakanda Forever at this point in
time and the movie is only about a month
away we are definitely due for that main
trailer and I would expect it Monday if
not the full trailer definitely a
special look with tons of new footage
and even regardless of the ticket sales
the trailer should be coming out this
week because like I said we're a month
away but then we have Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania coming in February of
next year so we only have five months
until that movie now the release date
window for this is actually coming from
a Marvel Studios producer Brian Gay in
an interview with One take news about
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania this is
what he said you know I'm very excited
to share that project with you guys
early next year at the moment one thing
I enjoyed about this movie is we've
always joked that Ant-Man movies go
small but this one's going to go big we
were able to show some things at d23 and
we will have more coming in the fall and
of course ahead of the premiere early
next year but I will say it's fun to
have the whole family back and they're
gonna go on a quite big adventure that I
think it's going to feel like a real
departure from the previous film so
according to Brian Gabe the trailer for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania is
coming fall of this year which means
that gives us a release date window
between September 23rd and December 21st
now we're obviously past September 23rd
and December would be way too close to
the actual release date to wait that
long now the Black Panther wakanda
forever trailer came 111 days before its
release date and if Marvel Studios is
planning on doing that same time frame
for Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
that should put us around the latter
half of October and today is the first
day of October so hopefully we have
about a month left to wait for the
official trailer for Ant-Man 3. and
hopefully we get our official
full-length trailer for Black Panther
wakanda forever this upcoming Monday so
let me know how excited everybody is for
these two trailers and of of course the
movies in general in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all MCU news for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf